[Musique]
bonjour à tous bienvenue sur le plateau
de la grande interview avec un invité
cette semaine
eh bien je crois que beaucoup
connaissent c'est jean louis etienne
merci jean louis etienne je ne sais pas
comment vous présenter je ne sais pas
comment vous présenter parce que il ya
des jeunes qui m'ont dit hier je quand
je leur ai dit que j'allais vous
rencontrer ils m'ont dit mais il
pourrait être le grand-père de greta
feinberg
vous avez une une réaction à sa part mon
âge effectivement je pourrais être son
grand-père et par filiation je dirais
c'est une jeunesse qui est aujourd'hui
je dirais qu'il a pris à coeur ces
questions environnementales et qui le
fait savoir
fortement à la beaucoup d'audace et là
il ya des bonnes choses en ce qu'elle
fait effectivement c'est tout ça s'est
fait avec le coeur et avec beaucoup de
d'impulsion ensuite derrière il faut
mettre faut mettre en oeuvre ces choses
là mais je crois que c'est ce à quoi il
faisait allusion
c'est à votre énergie à votre coeur et à
vos impulsions si je dis que vous êtes
médecin explorateur oui mais mais mais
mais pour moi et pour beaucoup d'autres
vous êtes quand même un monument un très
vite c'est vous qui avez été le premier
à atteindre le pôle nord en solitaire en
marche avec des traîneaux c'était en
quelle année le pôle nord cette
expédition qui vous a valu une notoriété
mondiale
alors c'était en 1986 avait fait une
tentative en 1985 d'abord et puis en
1986 j'ai réussi après effectivement 63
jours de marche le pôle nord est au
milieu de l'océan l'océan arctique donc
dans le grand nord et c'est cet axe
points virtuels si vous voulez ou pas
seul axe de rotation de la terre est
allé au pôle nord c'est avoir
rendez-vous au milieu de l'océan gelé et
donc quand vous partez du nord du canada
il faut affronter la banquise qui est
qui et cette couche de glace qui
recouvre l'océan qui fait un mètre de
mettre aujourd'hui qui diminue
d'ailleurs en épaisseur et c'est un
parcours du combattant surtout une
banquise très chaotique et des basses
températures qui fait que c'est un
et puis je les faire 1986 donc je le
répète c'était avant le gps avant le
téléphone portable donc c'était une
vraie
immersion une bourrée retraite intense
c'était incroyable vous vouliez prouver
qu a voulu prouver quelque chose vous à
vous même ou aux autres d'abord à moi
même je voulais prouver à moi même si
vous voulez pendant douze ans avant le
pôle nord j'avais été médecin de très
nombreuses expéditions en mer en
montagne en himalaya un peu partout et
donc j'allais avoir 40 ans et puis je me
dis maintenant c'est peut-être le moment
de ferme mon histoire ma propre
expédition et le pôle nord c'était
quelque chose qui m'allait bien au sens
où ce n'est pas technique si vous voulez
tirer un traîneau c'est pas technique je
n'étais pas un grand montagnards ni un
grand marin même si j'avais acquis de
l'expérience et ce pôle nord a été une
synthèse et entre la mer et la montagne
et j'essaie en 85 j'ai échoué en 86 j'ai
réussi et c'est effectivement quelque
chose qui est et un squelette squelette
de formation parce que j'ai dû résister
à la tentation de l'abandon par 63 jours
et je suis ressorti beaucoup plus
structurée si vous voulez c'était après
cet engagement qui était long et
difficile
alors après quand on a les images et
qu'on regarde votre album comme ça très
rapide il ya la traversée en ballon
1 ce ballon generali qui a duré beaucoup
moins de temps bien sûr mais qui était
quand même une grande opération risquée
très spectaculaire on va voir des images
c'était c'était absolument
extraordinaire car oui la traversée en
ballon
alors avant ça j'avais fait d'autres
tentatives à l'antarctique puis un
dirigeable et le ballon c'est quelque
chose que j'aimais bien d'abord cède si
vous êtes si les personnes qui nous
écoutent si elles sont montées en danse
et montgolfière c'est extraordinaire
c'est une vue sur la nature avec le
silence et j'aimais bien cette idée de
de traverser le pôle nord en ballon ge
l'idée c'était de partir du suisse verse
à dire au nord de l'europe passait au
pôle nord et arrive en alaska
mais les vents n'ont pas été favorables
pour aller 1-1 raskaï je me suis
retrouvé atterrir
je dirais clandestinement entre
guillemets yakoutie donc j'avais fait
bien sûr on avait une communication
radio les vents vont amener vers la
russie et j'ai j'ai atterri dans l'est
de
de la sibérie c'est effectivement cinq
jours pratiquement sans dormir intense
et je veux dire que c'est certainement
la plus dangereuse expédition que j'ai
fait
alors c'est amusant avec le recul mais
nous sommes chez nos amis russes vous
êtes arrivés chez eux de façon
clandestine
donc ils ont eu quand même un peu
d'inquiétude pour savoir qui était cet
énergumène qui débarquait comme ça du
ciel
oui alors c'était s'étaient organisés
dans le sens où effectivement mon équipe
a prévenu l'ambassade de france à moscou
qui a prévenu les autorités en disant il
ya un français qui arrivent en ballon
nous y tenons prenez en soin et
effectivement j'ai atterri dans un
dingue accouting avait rien il ya un
gros ami 8 qui est venu me chercher et
ensuite donc j'ai eu trois jours
d'interrogatoire avec le fsb
donc je rentrais tous les soirs à
l'hôtel c'était tout à fait conviviale
mais ils m'ont interrogé pour connaître
ce que j'avais vu ce que j'avais pu
découvrir et les raisons de mon parcours
et donc il y avait un truc c'est que
c'était rentrer sans visa donc il ya eu
un petit peu un protocole tout à fait de
bonnes qualités de bon aloi et ce qui
m'a permis de revenir en france
c'est déjà une époque où on rigolait pas
trop avec ce genre de de transgression
alors on va revenir en détail sur cette
vie absolument fantastique je voudrais
dire qu'on va encore beaucoup parlé de
vous la dans les mois qui viennent parce
que à l'heure où vous devriez
normalement partir en retraite vous vous
lancer dans un projet gigantesque polar
potes ça s'appelle c'est absolument
c'était une exploration que vous allez
tenter dans l'océan austral 1 donc vous
allez construire
vous allez nous l'expliqué on va
d'ailleurs voir les images
un gigantisme gigantesque plateforme 1
en france qui est conçu pour dérivés
autour du pôle sud
on va d'ailleurs là on voit les images
de cet engin sur lequel vous allez
embarquer pendant plus deux
faisant pratiquement et cette opération
est incroyable elle va d'ailleurs coûté
cher mais on peut dire aujourd'hui que
le budget est bouclé un public et privé
vont s'y mettre l'état français est un
certain nombre de grandes entreprises
jean louis etienne pourquoi ce pari
insensé qui ne s'est jamais fait un
d'aller au pôle sud de tourner autour du
pôle sud pour explorer ce que vous
appelez le puits carbone de la planète
oui alors là donc on va étudier l'océan
austral
depuis tout à l'heure je parlais de
l'océan arctique au pôle nord langue
change d'hémisphère on part dans
l'hémisphère sud
amy c'est un succès l'antarctique
antarctique c'est un immense continent
de glace qui est grand comme 28 fois la
france qui est grand comme l'europe et
les états unis réuni 7 absolument géant
et tout autour il y à l'océan que
l'appel l'océan austral en français
louanchi c'est le tour de l'antarctique
alors dû à son éloignement du à ces
états de mer difficiles duo coûte
important d'émissions pour y aller il ya
très peu de mission en fait qui ont
séjourné sur cet océan et toutes les
publications scientifiques se termine on
a besoin de mesures in situ de longue
durée ça veut dire on a besoin de
s'installer sur cet océan que les marins
ont baptisé les 50e hurlants
donc c'est un océan de tempête c'est
très ventée et donc pour rester sur cet
océan agité dans des bonnes conditions
de sécurité et de confort donc on a
dessiné puis nous allons construire le
polar pod
donc c'est un navire verticale comme
vous avez pu le montrer l'intérêt c'est
de fait le principe c'est de pouvoir
être descendre profond à 80 mètres sous
l'eau pour être pris dans des eaux
stable ce qui donne la stabilité à cette
a7 entre forme et vous l'avez évoqué
pourquoi est-ce qu'on y va c'est le
principal puits de carbone océanique de
la planète le co2 donc que l'on aimait à
l'excès qui responsables du
réchauffement climatique
une part de ce co2 est absorbée par les
eaux froides de l'océan austral mais on
ne connaît pas la performance et c'est
ce que nous allons mesurer pendant cette
opération continue qui va durer plus de
deux ans et puis vous allez essayer
d'observer les habitants de l'océan
austral c'est à dire la faune qu'on ne
connaît pas et qui parait-il
alors abrite un certain nombre d'animaux
dont on ignore d'aider des monstres non
oui oui
alors d'abord effectivement le polar pod
tel navire qui est épatant pour ça parce
que on n'a pas de moteur c'est un navire
autonome on n'a pas de moteur le moteur
principal qui nous déplacer le courant
le courant circumpolaire qui fait le
tour de l'antarctique
ça s'est ensuite nous avons six
éoliennes qui produisent notre et les
autres énergies
donc c'est un navire autonome il est
silencieux n'y a pas de moteur et comme
donc il ya pas de moteur et dans le
silence on va mettre à 80 mètres sous
l'eau ce qu'on appelle des hydrophones
rire des micros sous l'eau on va tendre
des micros sous l'eau et écouter et donc
on va faire un inventaire de la faune
par acoustique on connaît la signature
sonore aujourd'hui de toutes les espèces
et donc par écoute permanente
on va faire cet inventaire mais mais
vous avez souligné peut-être quelque
chose d'exceptionnel que nous allons
voir un espère c'est ce qu'on appelle le
calmar colossal tout le monde connaît le
calme
géant we call marque le salon connaît le
calmar géant mais la même vue mais les
pêcheurs qui vont dans les mains dans
ces mers australes pêcher ce qu'on
appelle la l'égide c'est un poisson qui
a une haute valeur sûre sur les marchés
c'est un poisson des mers froides et
donc qui séjournent sur cet océan
rencontre temps en temps des morceaux
comme ça deux des parties de ce calmars
de d'à peine 10 de ceux calmars donc
qu'ils recueillent dans leurs filets
dont la risée de point de vue génétique
on se rend compte que ce n'est pas le
calmar géant et non la baptiser le
calmar colossale dont nous allons
descendre une fibre optique avec une
caméra miniature à 2000 mètres sous
l'eau en espérant peut-être que veut que
le que ce curieux calmars colossal
viennent regarder notre caméra il qu'on
puisse ramener des images
alors vous allez embarquer un équipage
de combien cinq à six personnes très
international votre choix c'est cesser
d'avoir une représentation
internationale de d'experts et des et
d'ingénieurs alors c'est quand oui quand
j'ai commencé à parler de ce projet donc
je les présente et où vous êtes
unis en europe et donc j'ai reçu
beaucoup de lettres d'intérêt donc
aujourd'hui à 4 43 institutions de 12
pays qui participa à ce projet à bord il
y aura trois marins et quatre ingénieurs
des ingénieurs scientifiques qui vont
faire marcher tous ces instruments
ça s'apparente un peu à la station
spatiale internationale où en fait il y
à une multitude de capteurs beaucoup de
capteurs et peu de personnes à bord pour
le faire un marché puisqu'il y aura
quatre ingénieurs spécialisés qu'il faut
en tournée tout ça et les données seront
renvoyés bien sûr à terre c'est un
projet très moderne en open source c'est
à dire que la communauté scientifique
internationale aura accès à ces données
qui sont rares des données qui concerne
le climat qui concerne la biodiversité
qui concerne l'impact des activités
humaines sur cet océan et toutes ces
données ces images tous à notre présent
sur le terrain permettra d'animer un
projet pédagogique c'est un grand projet
pédagogique effectivement sur la
situation des océans aujourd'hui alors
on va et revenir vous parliez du spatial
j'ai le sentiment que le spatial c'est
votre regret dans la vie lorsque vous
n'avez pas été accepté dans une dent
dans une expédition spatiale et oui ou
non oui un peu 1
vous auriez voulu oui oui bien sûr vous
avez raison jamar cc c'est un regret
j'avais candidate et c'est en 1983 pour
la première fois nous vrai à une
candidature de nos militaires de civils
et j'ai su que j'étais pas loin d'avoir
été sélectionnés
claudie haigneré à cette époque-là été
sélectionnés ça veut pas dire qu'on
était sélectionné qu'on était admis
parce qu'après il y avait une multitude
de tests à passer et donc ça reste
effectivement une une frustration mais
vous savez je me dis d'une manière un
peu perverse je me dis que finalement
ils sont pas très loin il sera 400 km
voyez c'est la banlieue de la terre mais
en fait ça m'aurait ça m'aurait vraiment
plus de voir la planète de là haut c'est
une expérience unique et exceptionnel
mais je sais que c'est un sujet dont
vous parlez traitement
avec votre ami jean françois clervoy
jaloux et yann on va revenir sur cette
opération et puis surtout sur votre
parcours
on se retrouve dans quelques instants on
se retrouve sur le plateau de la de la
grande interview toujours avec jean
louis etienne ce médecin explorateur qui
lance un projet assez insensé qui est de
faire le tour du pôle sud de se laisser
porter par les courants qui tourne
autour du pôle sud dans l'océan austral
on en a parlé en détail c'est un projet
unique qui permettrait de faire avancer
la recherche sur ce puits carbone qui
existent de là bas et puis aussi sur la
faune et la flore et et toutes les a
toutes et toutes les problématiques
climatiques qui agite aujourd'hui et la
planète
mais jean louis etienne je vais vous
poser une question qui va vous paraître
bizarre comment on devient jean louis
etienne parce que vous franchement quand
on en parle à des enfants vous êtes un
héros pour pour plein d'enfants et on
est tous on est tous restés des enfants
comment devient jean louis etienne si
incroyable poids alors j'ai c'est vrai
que tu as un parcours singulier mais il
ya quand même eu une trajectoire une
ossature
je n'avais pas les notes pour entrer en
sixième bon je sais aujourd'hui avec les
progrès molaires de la médecine que
j'avais des déficits d'attention
je suis dyslexique dysorthographiques
donc dans l'école ou à l'école de jules
verne j'avais pas les nôtres suffisant
toujours entrer dans une formation de
professionnels de tourneur fraiseur et
ça a été une reprise de confiance sur
mon parcours scolaire est prof de maths
qui étaient là pour on l'avait laissée
happer je passe le srp après il est le
brevet professionnel et là on a dit mais
on était quelques-uns quelques galas
peut-être ils peuvent essayer de passer
le bac technique et c'est ce que j'ai
fait j'ai passé le bac technique tout
s'ouvrait devant moi donc est ce que
j'aime avec commencer par chypre et
pardonnez moi mais tout a commencé par
un échec scolaire alors au départ
absolument absolument seul scolaire
c'est à dire que je n'étais pas dans les
standards dans les standards de
de l'éducation nationale telle qu'elle
est telle qu elle est exigeante si vous
voulez donc et donc formation
professionnelle cap2 tourneur fraiseur
le bac technique et là je me dis qu'est
ce que je fais et j'ai décidé de faire
médecine
j'avais envie d'une implication sociale
j'aimais les sciences naturelles
j'ai fait médecine mais mais pour
revenir à mon parcours comment est-ce
qu'on devient jean louis etienne en fait
j'ai renoué avec le jean louis etienne
petit quand j'étais je suis dans la
campagne dans un village de 800
habitants la maison donné derrière sur
les champs j'ai aimé vivre dehors j'ai
toujours aimé le vivre dehors
moi j'étais timide et fait la nature
était un peu mon refuge si vous voulez
puis puis la toise à mes ambitions je
grimper dans les arbres pour aller
chercher les lépi au mois de mai pour
les apprivoiser en fait j'avais cette
vie proche de la nature et je rêvais de
faire des expéditions se trouve savoir
ce que c'était j'imaginais partir avec
des caravanes de porter et puis et puis
j'étais interne en chirurgie dont à
podor fait médecine
les félins tc tandis le seul internat en
chirurgie oui pourquoi la chirurgie pas
ce que c'était c'était le tourneur
fraiseur qui se retrouvaient là
exactement vous avez raison la chirurgie
s'était de nouveau le la médecine si
vous voulez le manuel en médecine et je
me souviens très bien j'étais étudiant
en médecine je vous demande et en
chirurgie à l'hôpital un chef de service
si je pouvais assister aux opérations
j'étais en troisième année de médecine
il me disait venez tous les matins
j'étais là et un jour il ya une urgence
de la main l'inter n'était pas là et le
chef de service des arts à la dame du
bloc à billet etienne habillé tienne sa
soeur grands moments de ma vie je
faisais le lien si vous voulez entre ce
que vous évoquez c'est vrai le travail
manuel du tourneur fraiseur avec la
chirurgie donc j'ai passé le concours
d'internât et j'adorais l'orthopédie
l'orthopédie on met des vis des plaques
des broches
j'avais une certaine agilité si vous
voulez mais cette histoire de faire des
expéditions étaient toujours là et je me
suis dit mais je peux proposer mes
services de médecins pour faire des
expéditions et c'est comme ça que tout a
commencé
c'est la médecine qui m'a mis le pied à
l'étrier
et des expéditions dont je rêvais quand
j'étais jeune et pendant douze ans j'ai
fait des expéditions tabarly l'himalaya
beaucoup de choses comme ça m'est arrivé
la rencontre qui a changé vos délices et
c'est la rencontre avec eric tabarly
aussi quelque part parce que il vous a
embarqué sur le bateau
oui important eric tabary parce qu'en
fait j'avais fait une dizaine d'années
d'expédition et je me disais bon
peut-être maintenant il faut trouver
quelque chose et donc j'ai rencontré
eric tabarly en cherchant à leur
encontre est vraiment eric m'a proposé
d'embarquer et son médecin et ça a été
une rupture avec l'université je dirais
c'est c'est à ce moment là que je je dis
je parais rythme pour vous un départ ça
ait duré un an
donc j'étais assistant à la fac j'ai
rompu avec cette l'université et puis
donc ça a été après 40 ans le moment de
de structurer ma vie autour de ces
expéditions et l'arrivée au pôle nord
quelques années après je me souviens
très bien du moment où je me suis dit
mais ça ça va être ma vie organiser des
expéditions et donc je le fais depuis
toujours et comme vous avez évoqué tout
à fait j'ai passé l'âge de la retraite
et je continue parce que parce que c'est
ce que j'aime bien et je dis tout le
temps aux personnes qui m'écoutent si
vous avez une idée un désir quelque
chose un peu englouti des fois c'est
précieux l'idée quand il faut se
consacrer aux choses que le même ça veut
pas dire que c'est facile mais au moins
quand on est sur une veine des choses
direction comme ça qui vous amène
quelque chose qui vous plaît c'est
beaucoup plus facile mais il faut dit
consacrer toujours du temps du travail
de la persévérance c'est comme ça je
dirais entre guillemets qu'on devient
jean-louis vous vous pensez que quand on
veut on peut
quand on veut c'est nécessaire de s'y
consacrer
ça veut pas dire qu'on peut comme ça
mais il ya toujours un apprentissage et
il ya des moments de découragement il ya
la tentation de l'abandon j'y suis pas
étranger gelée de temps en temps le
projet polar potes qu'on a évoqué qui
est une immense cathédrale dix ans
de travail j'ai failli abandonner
souvent mais je sais d'expérience que de
résister à la tentation permet de passer
des seuils est souvent envoyé jean marc
c'est une discussion avec quelqu'un un
film qu'on va voir qui vous donne le
courage livre qui vous lie mai mais bon
sens oui qui vous redonne l'énergie
c'est ça qui est important et on me dit
souvent mais vous vous avez la passion
c'est facile mais non dans la patience
et comme le feu s'ils ne mettaient pas
des bûches ça s'arrête donc c'est
toujours aller chercher cette énergie
alors nécessaire d'adhérer composent ce
parcours là un spectaculaire
impressionnant vous a placé dans la
bataille écologique vous a pas se placer
au coeur de du débat pour le contre le
réchauffement climatique
comment comment vous vous vous juger
aujourd'hui cette situation est ce que
véritablement la planète est en danger
premier point et deuxième point est ce
qu on s'y prend bien pour prendre en
compte ce danger le réchauffement
climatique est une réalité ce n'est pas
on en a fait une discussion populaire
ce n'est pas un sujet de discussion
populaire parce que la tempe et là la
température moyenne de la planète à
l'échelle planétaire et moyennes s'est
réchauffée de 1 degré en un siècle
personne ne peut percevoir un
réchauffement moyen d'un degrés en un
siècle
voyez et c'est ce petit degré là qui est
en train de entraîné petit à petit des
dérèglements climatiques
je fais des comparaisons avec le corps
humain quand on va bien on l'a 37
cantona un degré de plus à la 38 en
médecine label cinq fabriques hull une
petite fièvre on couvre quelque chose
la planète l année là aujourd'hui et
c'est une machine qui a une énorme
inertie et le responsable le connais
c'est l'excès de gaz carbonique qui est
dans l'air donc on a pas d'aspirateur à
gaz carbonique
il ya deux choses à faire d'une part
limiter les émissions et bien sûr en
limitant les émissions qui sont dues à
la combustion du charbon du pétrole et
du gaz
on sait qu'on en a besoin encore si vous
voulez c'est pour ça que
c'est compliqué à mettre en oeuvre il
faut être exigeant aujourd'hui
et la deuxième chose et qu'est ce qui
peut sortir l'excès de gaz carbonique de
l'air c'est la nature c'est le verre
c'est la photosynthèse
c'est le pigment de chlorophylle donc
limiter les émissions multiplier si vous
voulez préserver préserver la nature
mais là on touche la nature bien sûr
mais la limitation des émissions on
touche si vous voulez au l'économie
mondiale on voit bien que ce qui
viennent se passer avec des réductions
de mobilité etc
la machine climatique qu'elle est en
panne aujourd'hui donc il va falloir
trouver des des énergies décarbonées
c'est ça l'avenir trouver des énergies
décarbonées le risque c'est évidemment
le réchauffement climatique
mais l'autre risque c'est aussi la
réduction de l'activité économique vous
avez des courants écologique qui prône
un arrêt de la croissance
un changement de modèle de comportement
au niveau de la production ou de la
consommation où ils se situent le jean
louis etienne aujourd'hui là dedans jean
jaurès disait une phrase que j'aime
beaucoup aller à l'idéal
tout en comprenant le réel je trouve
c'est ce mariage là qu'il faut arriver à
faire parce qu'il est évident que depuis
que nous parlons le nombre de voitures
un peu moins d'avions aujourd'hui qui
circulent des productions d'énergie qui
se font donc il est évident qu'on ne
peut pas arrêter si vous voulez la
machine économique
c'est ce mariage qu'il faut faire je
vous donne un exemple je fais des
conférences d'aller avec des écoles
d'ingénieurs
on parle du recyclage mais le recyclage
souvent dans la tête s'est recyclé des
vieux trucs qu'on a mis à la poubelle
mais il faut travailler en amont c'est à
dire aujourd'hui si on veut entrer dans
une économie circulaire c'est à dire que
tout est recyclable
il faut aujourd'hui travailler sur ce
que seront les matériaux et les suer les
et les réalisations de demain il faut
faire en sorte que ce les matériaux
qu'on utilise puisse comme dans la
nature si vous voulez revenir dans le
circuit initial c'est ça l'économie
circulaire mais ça demande effectivement
deux choses pour arriver à améliorer
d'une part
une action comportementale il faut que
chacun soit responsable c'est-à-dire
qu'ils aient conscience que chacun a ses
activités impact la nature impacte notre
des questions environnementales et
deuxièmement il va falloir trouver des
solutions de manière à ce que l'humanité
se développent dans des bonnes
conditions de santé et d'environnement
mais ce sont des investissements
technologiques il faut faire à la fois
donc comportementale et technologique
c'est là dans ces deux mamelles là je
dirais que sur les solutions
auriez vous pu être ministre de
l'environnement pourquoi ne l'avez-vous
jamais été vous avez refusé
oui je ça m'a été proposée par le
président mitterrand
il m'avait convoqué en fait il m'avait
invité par dont un rendez vous à
l'elysée je me souviens très bien
c'était de 19h à 19h30 et donc il me
proposait un accompagnement politique si
vous voulez d'abord un accompagnement
aux législatives et ensuite un poste de
ministre de l'environnement et donc je
je le dis mais président je parlais
rébus et il me dit c'est quoi les remus
dit c'est un volcan en antarctique c'est
une expédition sur laquelle je
travaillais depuis déjà trois ans un
volcan en antarctique et le président a
dit là monsieur je ne vais pas pouvoir
vous accompagner et en sortant de
l'elysée je me suis dit mais c'était une
opportunité une occasion j'en avais
parlé haroun tazieff que je connaissais
bien il m'a dit jean-louis la politique
c'est un métier il faut être
on n'est pas taillé pour ça s'éteint
c'est tu as bien fait et j'ai continué
si vous voulez dans cette veine là dans
lequel je me déploie je me sens bien
c'est de devenir plus pédagogue aller
sur le terrain témoigner et devenir
pédagogue
c'est là c'est là où je me sens le plus
le plus à l'aise le plus efficace mais
jean louis etienne pour terminer un
conseil un seul conseil à tous les ados
qui peuvent nous regarder parce que
c'est à ce moment là quand au moment de
l'adolescence là qu'on rêve quand vous
regardant alors je leur dirai suivait la
voie de vos rêves
même si le chemin est difficile parce
que c'est là qu'on se réalise
et toutes choses qui nous ont fait rêver
qu'on n'a pas réalisé sacré sans s'en
rendre compte des frustrations qui sont
des freins à la réalisation donc je vous
le répète suivait la voie de vorey même
si le chemin est difficile
bon merci beaucoup d'avoir accepté
d'être avec nous avec de nous faire
partager cette part de rêve et de
réalité d'ailleurs cette émission est
terminée jean louis etienne merci pour
toutes ces leçons de vie on va vous
suivre bien sûr autour de l'antarctique
vous retrouvez cette émission en
rediffusion sur l'antenne mais aussi sur
les réseaux sociaux sur le site internet
de rtl france pour un tv a très vite
[Musique]